votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
[Applaudissements]
reichert
howlett en direct
[Musique]
m
le film dans lequel il joue et
exceptionnel vraiment christophe carlier
on va en parler dans l'instant je pense
qu'il va être primé de partout celui-ci
bientôt il va le primé par le public
surtout mère n'aime pas le public est
attirée par tout le monde on laisse ça à
mettre d'accord et ahmed en plus les
séries à spectacle km qui passe samedi
soir sur ces 8 aïe ça va être un carton
d'audience aussi installé des la carte
dès la première fois ci voulait pas vu
regardez le spectacle d'ahmed parce
qu'il sera donc samedi
sur ces 8 et 24 et 25 décembre à
l'olympia je pense qu'ils les dernières
dates à l'olympia on voulait finir en
beauté les rhénans d'après terminé à
reed aurait lancé ferme et madame tout
le monde
monsieur sylla s'il a fait passer de
labo on est en émission attendez m'étais
metelo metal mais on travaille monsieur
on ne peut pas les gens comme ça
pourquoi ils ont tous été la cause de
lui mais non mais si ça n'allait pas
changer maintenant j'ai pas changé
depuis les frères ça serait plutôt des
gens je connais l'arrêté vous êtes
cernés si on a aussi me faisais un autre
tatouage a peut-être des capitales pour
m'entraîner parce que je suis mauve est
d'ailleurs je me sente rené hier soir
allez sur la capitale ouais attention
c'est parti faire un collabo la capitale
du danemark
tu donnes mark adams analogues mais l'ol
a bien fait s'entraîner
incollable à son nom alors à la merci
d'être là je suis très content il est de
plus en plus beau suisse hier une belle
peau ouais
[Rires]
juste une personne qui travaille chez
dermatherm ce que tu regarde en premier
chez une personne sap au château et la
petit parfum musqué banier
j'arrive pas trouvé depuis tout à
l'heure ça m'agace masataka soit pas
dire tout de suite je vais trouver me
trouver ban a trouvé on s'appelle on se
reconnaît pas dans une émission médias
et pas assez fort à la match je crois
qu'ils qui vous a dit quelque chose
c'est d'y accéder au top comme ça tu
sais pas il me dit écoute à l'occasion
d'annoncer un peu dans le cinéma tu
feras des seconds rôles je peux faire
des premiers héros non j'ai pas dit non
mais c'est vrai qu'il fera circuler pas
mal dans le cinéma
vous êtes le joueur devait commencer un
petit peu circulé mais je peux jouer à
la lumière oui vous savez ce que c'est
les audiences radio une fois le
lendemain à un autre c'est comme l'école
des fans voilà il y en a un qui a perdu
la semaine mon les audiences radio vous
savez ce que c'est s'il ya plein de
radio et c'est toujours au repas qui
perd à la fin
c'est parti tu es parti après le doux
parfum frais
[Applaudissements]
sarrès commence doucement tout vassal à
tous reconnu c'est connu c'est plus le
fossé dans les détails ça super sain ce
qui se passe et gilou c'est qui ça on
doit on doit jouer le mec tous mais le
mec d'être actif
quand je t'ai pas trop excuse moi tiens
ce que j'aime penser avec le truc si
l'asie et autres imite assure eric roy
gamin problème des vases et autres
imitations ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
cela était avéré